All right. Jessica Schneider
thanks so much. CNN senior
supreme court analyst joins me,
Joan, uh, just another two days
here. Um Alito bought the court.
What's going on behind the
scenes? Well they're obviously
divided because if they had the
five votes, and that's what you
need is five votes to either
grant the Biden administration's
request to put everything on
hold and let the merits of the
controversy play out. While the
pill is available just without
any kind of new restrictions on
it, or to outright deny it, so
neither side of this battle had
the requisite five votes without
some sort of protest from other
justices, I imagine ah, I
justice who wants justices might
be trying to pick off those try
to call us a majority, and you
don't know what's being written
in dissent. That's another thing
that could be costing time when
justice Alito put the original
deadline on and we should make
clear to viewers. Justice Alito
is handling this only because he
happens to be the justice who
oversees the fifth circuit court
of appeals. It's just it's just
happenstance that the man who
wrote the Dobbs opinion
overturning all of
constitutional abortion rights
is now the one who is kind of
the point. I'm sorry. The fifth
circuit is that in Texas or is
an official over the fifth
circuit is based in New Orleans.
But it's over three states that
includes Texas, where the case
originally came from Jake, so
clearly, they're not. They don't
have a majority, and if they
have a narrow majority, somebody
would want to somebody on the
dissenting side. Maybe trying to
right. We don't know. All we
know for sure is they were not
able to resolve. Solve this. And
as the Biden administration was
making, you know, one of its
many pitches and its many
filings to try to say you cannot
it was a I was surprised at how
forceful the Biden
administration came in in its
last filing, just saying, you
cannot believe what kind of
chaos you're going to cause if
you do not postpone the effect
of these lower court orders, and
as as just one judge overruling
the food and drug
administration, exactly and just
so our audience knows also, this
is not a case like what they
resolved in June, June had to do
with the constitutional right to
abortion, you know, overturning
nearly a half century of that,
but this has to do with the
authority of. An agency that has
expertise in a particular area
over food and drug
administration to say to test
drugs to review to look at what
scientific determinations are
necessary to find a drug safe
and effective and the lower
court judges in this case of
second guess that in the Biden
administration says, if you
allow that you'll not only
throwing doubt any kind of
access to medication abortion,
you will jeopardize the approval
process for a host of other
existing in new drugs. It's
crazy. I told you that they
didn't have five votes to keep
mythic. Kristen I told you that
I said, who's the fifth vote? I
don't even know that they have
four. But wait a minute. I just
want to make sure that's not
even the question. Yet the
question is just as procedural
matter, so okay. So I'll give
you that. You're right that that
you don't even come close to
even deciding in a temporary way